what we are joined to discuss this by
the right of the fax machine user at
Messines thank you very much for being
with us well let's start shall we with
the biggest question there what can be
done if anything to prevent attacks such
as this yeah I think the number one
things that we could all focus on inside
of the community is to be crystal clear
about where the Orthodox religion of
Islam stands on these things the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
said the Muslim is the one from whose
hands and tongue people are safe and he
said you know wish for your neighbor
what you wish for yourself he said peace
and busing to be upon him loves those on
earth and those in heaven will love you
these are universal teachings in the
religion of Islam that are just the
basis that the whole religion is based
upon and it's really important that we
get crystal clear about what actual
orthodox islam teaches versus you know
the alternative narrative being pushed
by certain people isn't though a problem
with the Petoskey earth at the
interpretation of the Quran in the sense
that there are a number of different
interpretations of key points with Islam
of course I mean that is the case with
in for example Catholicism but with
Catholicism you have the Magisterium you
have the ultimate authority that is what
is missing from from Islam isn't it well
in the religion of Islam we have like
not all interpretations are equal some
interpretations are just plainly wrong
and they're the ones that need to be
called out there logically wrong they're
misinterpretations they're not based on
what we would call the inheritors of the
prophets which are the legitimate
scholars of Islam they're based on
nothing and that's how people use the
Quran to indoctrinate people take one or
two verses take them out of context and
not let people look at all of the
hundreds or even thousands of verses and
teachings for completely contradict
these and I think anybody you know whose
objective and has common sense and also
you know it's a religion of love and it
is a religion of peace and if we take a
serious look at I think that becomes
very clear and when people are explicit
about this I mean for me the ultimate
prevent strategy are the Orthodox
teachings of the religion of Islam and
they were pushed by Muslim scholars by
in
arms all across the country I think it
there's never been more unanimous
support for the loving truthful peaceful
forgiving compassionate teachings of the
religion but I'm soon and I hope you
take this at this this question in the
senton which is delivered there are a
number of people who have been raised
but perhaps in the Western religious
tradition who look at countries which
describe themselves as Islamic can be
optic Saudi Arabia and they look at the
treatment of their own people you know
the executions the beheading speaking of
the cutting off of hands and see what if
is that is this religion of peace how
can interview how can States which set
themselves up under the Quran at behave
in such a fashion yeah and there are
corrupt governments and there are unjust
into you know unjust attempts to
interpret the law but the Muslims who
believe in the Quran and believe what
the prophet or we believe it's a
religion of mercy the Prophet peace and
blessings be upon him with senators
Erasmus and they'll either mean a mercy
to all of creation and so it's very
clear for us that you will get
governments who often as a show you know
will do these things but we should focus
on the authentic teachings of Islam that
Western Muslims are brought up with you
know we shouldn't even call the people
that do the extreme things you shouldn't
even call them extreme Muslims we should
call them extremely bad Muslims you know
the terrorists are extremely bad Muslims
I happen to be a vegetarian now if I say
I'm an extreme vegetarian in fact I'm
such an extreme vegetarian I'm going to
go any a thousand McDonald's Big Macs
does that really make me an extreme
vegetarian and what I'm doing goes
completely against what I'm saying I am
and then it's really soon I take the
semantics of the point that you're
making but even if we describe them as
extreme extremist Muslims they are still
part of the faith by that very
terminology well the extent to well by
the prophets they're finishing peace and
blessings be upon the Muslim is the one
from whose hands and tongue people are
safe so by that definition you know what
are we talking about the extent to which
you're trying to harm innocent people is
the extent to which you are
contradicting the teachings of the
religion of Islam
and I think we should all be on board
with this because the Muslim community
by and large completely condemns and
condemns terrorism and the British
community completely condemns terrorism
so we could all get on the same page
here and say look the religion of Islam
is a peaceful and beautiful religion and
we don't want to be pushing the ideology
of the terrorists that's the last thing
we want so let and be the people who are
at the forefront of countering the
terrace narrative are the Muslim
scholars who are teaching the beautiful
loving forgiving compassionate teachings
of the religion and I think you know
wish for your neighbor what you wish for
yourself wish for Humanity the Prophet
peace and blessings be upon him scepters
wish for Humanity what you wish for
yourself and I would love to see there I
would love for everybody to be as clear
about this as I am right now you know
the religion of Islam is a beautiful
peaceful religion some people are trying
to twist it but they were getting it
wrong at moment how best then for the
community to push this measure given the
fact that you know for whatever reason
you know bigger because of a lack of
language skills because of fear of
integration there are parts of the
Muslim community that have become
compartmentalised away from from from
British society at all at least in part
I best then for those to push this
message well the best way that I can see
the push the message is we already know
one thing we know about Muslims is they
love the religion of Islam and they r we
really believe in it so let's be really
clear about what all the authentic
teachings of the religion of Islam the
Prophet peace and blessings be upon him
said I was sent to no other reason than
to perfect noble character that's aslam
right there you know it's a religion of
purifying your heart letting go of the
anger and the hatred in the fear that
can overtake us sometimes and instead
taking the straight path the path of
love and peace and compassion that's the
essential teachings of all of the
religions of all the prophets that's
what we believe in let's be really clear
about that and the people that should be
commended the most are the Muslim
scholars and speakers and activists who
are working tirelessly twenty-four/seven
probably the more to counter the whole
terrorism thing than than almost any
other segments of society are the Muslim
scholars who are going out there saying
this is a religion of rathma we start
every prayer with
rahmani raheem in the name of Allah the
most loving the most compassionate than
most kind this is the religion that we
want to promote and I think that's the
prevent strategy that doesn't even
require the government to help out
because we're all doing it all the time
anyway that's what it looks like to me
mamoun Youssef thanks very much for
joining us is going in this lunchtime we
appreciate it